Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
whatever you can imagine I can create
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie DC just
dropped a brand new Blue Beetle trailer so
we'll break it down obviously there's a bunch
of stuff happening right now because the flash
is coming out so I'll explain how everything is
connected and what's going to be happening going
forward with the reboot because James Gunn also
just did a big podcast recently sort of clarifying
where everything fits the next couple of years
especially with the movies that are still coming
out this year like Blue Beetle The Flash movie
Aquaman 2. I'm also doing a giveaway for tickets
to The Flash movie all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just post all your favorite
moments from the Blue Beetle trailers on the video
I do have a bunch of videos for The Flash post
credit scenes full breakdown Easter eggs all that
stuff coming out later this week after it comes
out in theaters so don't worry I have a bunch of
stuff planned for that there's so much stuff going
on in that movie that we have to talk about but
we get a little new footage of Jenny giving Jaime
Reyes the Blue Beetle Scarab at chord Industries
when he thinks he's going to get the job in the
big belly Burger case the funny thing here there's
so many Easter eggs in this trailer if you watched
any of the arrowverse shows like Arrow The Flash
Supergirl any of the arrowverse shows just in
general big belly Burger is a big DC location
they used it many times on all those series
you've only got one belly you don't tell me
that so why not treat it right I'm starving
there's a big belly burger at big belly
Burger we put our best ingredients into
our Burgers now that's what I'm talking
about so you can put the best burgers
into your belly so this one has the triple
stack that's for you thank you go ahead
you go to big belly Burger is always going
to taste like big belly Burger give me full
of grease and salt I thought those were the
secret ingredients hell no ma'am quite the
opposite even superheroes eat here for the super
quality salad now we go get a big gummy Burger
there better be curly fries
in there big Billy burger
now serving Star City and Central
City coming soon to National City
kind of makes me want a burger right now too
they're in Palmyra City Florida which is a
reference to Ray Palmer's version of the atom
there was a Ryan Choi version of the atom in
the Justice League Snyder cut but according to
Zack Snyder I don't think we were supposed to
see him become the atom like where the full
suit Go full Adam until later movies I don't
think they'd ever planned on doing an atom
Solo movie but I think the plan was for him
to return in the cyborg Solo movie that they
had originally wanted to do years and years
ago that would have featured him just continuing
to work at Star Labs because that would have been
a big location in the movie they never really
explained what happened to the ray Palmer Adam
in the Snyder verse but they probably would
have just explained his story through Ryan
choi's storyline there's a much bigger scene
of him fighting car packs later in the movie
without his mask on confirming that it won't
just be his Consciousness inside a robot like
the comics it'll be more traditional with him
working for Victoria cord in trying to kill him
using another suit built by cord Industries to
take the Scara back by force but in the comics
car pack started out as a normal human who was
a villain to the original Blue Beetle way back
in the day Dan Garrett during his many fights
against Dan Garrett he discovered a secret lab
belonging to Ted cord's Uncle more connections
to the second version of Blue Beetle the lab
contained an indestructible suit of armor that
you see in the trailer here he couldn't get it to
work and wound up electrocuting himself killing
himself his mind got transferred into the robot
so he basically became this Immortal robot with
the mind of a human and because he was Immortal
he just eventually lived on to become a villain
to the second version of Blue Beetle Ted court
so 50 50 on whether or not car packs survived the
end of the movie like whether or not Blue Beetle
winds up killing him in the fight or he decides
to turn good and somehow dies after trying to
help Blue Beetle his villain named car packs is
also a reference to the hard EXO skeletons that
a lot of animals particularly bugs beetles in
this case have like they're both wearing suits
even though the reach themselves had nothing to
do with car packs he's like an earlier Golden
Age villain that then transitioned to the Silver
age it seems like what's happening with the reach
in the movie is it'll just be light references
to them like there'll be a couple scenes where
they allude to what's happening with the reach in
general you start to see it broadcasting signals
more Cosmic looking scenes I think they'll just
reference what's going on that in the history
of the reach and when they start digging into
the history of the Scarab like how Ted Court
originally found the Scarab what happened with
the Dan Garrett version The Blue Beetle how he
found the Scarab the way they're talking about
the movie The Way James Gunn has been talking
about the DCU going forward it sounds like there
won't be a Blue Beetle sequel movie even though
this movie looks solid it's supposed to be like
a smaller movie it seems like it'll be a lot of
fun the way the James Gunn and the other people
behind DC now are talking about the Blue Beetle
character especially some of the trade magazines
recently say that Blue Beetle is probably going
to cross over in the Booster Gold HBO series that
they're going to be working on the next couple of
years but they didn't say when that's coming out
there's been a long history of Blue Beetle and
Booster Gold crossovers in the comics and if you
watch Smallville episodes back in the day there
was a big Crossover with those characters
with the Jaime Reyes version of Blue Beetle
you're an Excel right
they haven't said who's going to be playing
the Booster Gold of the new James Gunn DCU but
if James Gunn said that a bunch of his Guardians
of the Galaxy actors like his Marvel actors he's
worked with before will probably transition into
DC roles at some point in the future I think that
Chris Pratt would actually play a solid Booster
Gold he'll also be continuing as the Star-Lord
character in like Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty like
at the end of Guardians of the Galaxy 3 it says
the legendary Star-Lord will return it was meant
to be a big joke about how he called himself the
legendary Star-Lord in the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie but nobody knew who he
was so because now James Gunn is taking over DCU
don't be surprised if you see a lot of prominent
Marvel actors showing up in DC roles as different
characters but they also continue in other Marvel
movies so it'll be a little bit weird but not
that weird the other big connection with stuff
that James Gunn is already working on is with
The Peacemaker character so Peacemaker in Blue
Beetle have a big Connection in the comics he
served as sort of a mentor to the young Jaime
Reyes for a while and the funny thing is really
early theory that might not wind up doing this
but I do think it to be really really funny just
because Peacemaker is such a ridiculous character
in the comics they use crisis on infinite versus
big Multiverse movie to sort of tie up a lot of
their continuity and clean things up behind the
scenes after that going forward they explained
that psycho pirate was a character who remembered
everything that came before a crisis before this
big hard reboot in the DCU like the James Gunn
era of DC films it would be hilarious if they
just make that peacemaker's character and he's the
only person that remembers everything from before
the reboot because he came from before the reboot
in one of his big character traits is that he's
always yelling about crazy conspiracy theories so
it just totally in character for him to be yelling
about a big DC reboot but nobody believes him and
he's the only one that remembers and it's actually
true it actually happened Superman's an alien he's
got a poop fetish what the out of here oh yeah
where do you get this nonsense Google I'm telling
you Superman used to be completely different the
Justice League looked completely different what's
going on why doesn't anybody else remember this
James Gunn did confirm that Peacemaker season
2 will start immediately after Superman Legacy
comes out but that's not coming out till 2025
so it'll be a couple more years for Peacemaker
season two but do not be surprised if you also see
him crossing over with the Blue Beetle character
like Blue Beetle showing up at some point during
Peacemaker season two this is him actually talking
about where the Blue Beetle character sort of
fits into the DC continuity just in general and
The Flash movie as well the MCU and now the DCU
in film which really doesn't start I mean the
first DCU character for sure is Blue Beetle in the
First full DC move DCU movie is Superman if there
were Alex Luther in this movie and there's a lot
of other villains so it may not be like and you
are the best Lex let's admit it we know you're
the best Lex come on you're being funny I'm not
being funny you're definitely the best Lex really
definitely so what he's basically saying there is
that he consider Blue Beetle to be the first real
DCU character in The Flash movie for instance even
though it sets up the big DC reboot with all the
Multiverse stuff that's happening in the movie
don't worry I'll talk about that later this week
because some of it does get into spoilers he's
not wrong either Michael Rosenbaum is one of the
best Lex luthors that they've ever had he doesn't
really consider The Flash movie or Aquaman 2
to be true DCU movies once you see The Flash
movie you'll understand what he means by that
it is still very much a Snyder verse movie with
some ties to what's happening with the reboot and
even though Jason Momoa said that he's definitely
coming back in the DC movies it sounds like
he will be a different character right now it
just seems like Lobo like he's been talking about
Lobo I did a video about it a while ago too so as
we get more details about that of course I'll do
videos and we'll start getting Aquaman 2 trailers
later this year so we'll be talking about it then
as well the way that James Gunn is talking about
it a lot of actors will stay the same like Gal
Gadot is still going to continue to play Wonder
Woman even though she won't show up for a while
what they're going to do is for a lot of those
actors that will continue as their care characters
they'll just retune their backstories a little bit
to fit with what's going on in the backstory of
the new DCU for example Wonder Woman's backstory
gonna change a little bit because they're doing
that the mascara series which is kind of like
Game of Thrones with Wonder Woman characters but
set years before Wonder Woman was born more than 5
000 years ago so when Wonder Woman does show up
in present day after the events of that series
they'll have to retune her backstory so that it
makes sense with what's already happened there's
a bunch of stuff coming up I got a bunch of Flash
videos planned so be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that also Marvel
secret Invasion episodes are starting next
week so it is going to be crazy there'll be so
much stuff going on click here for my brand new
Superman and Justice League Flash trailer video
and click here for the opening scenes from Marvel
secret Invasion episode one they posted the
full opening scenes they're actually pretty
solid thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!